طلب الائتلاف من اجل النزاهه والمساءله
الفلسطينيه امان السلطه الفلسطينيه
باحترام سياده القانون وتنفيذ قرارات
المحاكم بالافراج عن نشطاء ومواطنين
معتقلين لديها من بين هؤلاء المعتقلين
الموظف ائتلاف امان فخر الرنتيسي المعتقل
لدى جهاز المخابرات منذ عشره ايام وقد حصل
على قراري افراج رفض جهاز المخابرات
تنفيذهما في الوقت نفسه طالبت الهيئه
الفلسطينيه المستقله لحقوق الانسان السلطه
الفلسطينيه باحترام قرارات القضاء دون
تاخير
ووقت مؤسسات حقوقيه فلسطينيه اعتقال اكثر
من اربعين ناشطا في الضفه الغربيه خلال
الايام الاخيره معظمهم من المحسوبين على
حركه حماس وارجعت مصادر حقوقيه فلسطينيه
لاعتقالات على خلفيه فوز الجناح الطلابي
لحماس في انتخابات ابرز جامعتين في الضفه
وهما جامعه بيرزيت والنجاح
معنى من بيت لحم المحامي فريد الاطرش مدير
الهيئه المستقله لحقوق الانسان في جنوب
الضفه الغربيه سيد فريد
هلا اوضحت لنا
الاشكاليه والتبريرات التي تعطى
الاعتقال هؤلاء الفلسطينيين على الرغم من
صدور قرارات قضائيه
بالافراج عنهم
يعني بدايه شكرا على الاستضافه
وعلى السؤال حقيقه لا توجد اي تبريرات واي
تبريرات في احتجاز مواطنين خلافا للقانون
هي غير مقبوله وهي مخالفه للقانون الاساسي
الفلسطيني وايضا الاتفاقيات الدوليه التي
انضمت اليها دوله فلسطين وبالتالي هذا
الاعتقال هو اعتقال تعسفي وخارج اطار
القانون طالما ان هناك ايضا قرري قرارين
محكمه بالافراج عن المواطن
الرنديسي وبالتالي الهيئه المستقله لحقوق
الانسان اصدرت بيان اليوم طالبت فيه
بالافراج الفوري عن المواطن دون قيد او
شرط واحترام قرارات المحاكم قرارات
المحاكم يجب احترامها ويجب عدم
يعني البقاء عدم تنفيذها والاتفاف عليها
وبالتالي يجب احترام قرارات المحاكم
يعني يبقى السؤال عندما يتم
محاججه الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه
بهذا الامر ماذا يكون الرد وعلى خلفيه
ماذا يتم الاعتقال اذا
يعني للاسف الاعتقال السياسي هو موجود
وجاء نتيجه الانقسام الاسود ونتيجه يعني
تداعيات الوضع الداخلي الفلسطيني
والاجهزه الامنيه ودائما تبرر ان هناك تهم
تتعلق في حيازه سلاح او اثاره الاعراض او
تهم تتعلق
يعني
جنائيه وجزائيه من اجل التغطيه على توقيف
المواطنين على خلفيه سياسيه وايضا المهم
هنا انه بعد صدور بعد عرضهم على القضاء
والنيابه وصدور قرارات بالافراج عنهم يتم
تاخير تنفيذ قرارات الافراج عنهم ويستمروا
باحتجازهم دون وجه حق وبالتالي هذا
الاحتجاز من وجهه نظرنا كهيئه مستقله
لحقوق الانسان حقوقيين هذا الاحتجاز يعد
حجزا للحريه وخلاف القانون وبالتالي يجب
محاسبه من
يستمر باحتجاز مواطنين بشكل تعسفي وخلافا
للقانون ويجب الافراج عن المواطن بشكل
فوري ووقف هذه الاعتقالات السياسيه
التعسفيه المخالفه للقانون الاساسي
الفلسطيني والمخالفه لكل المواثيق الدوليه
التي هي دوله فلسطين شكرا لك فريد الاطرش
مدير الهيئه المستقله لحقوق الانسان في
جنوب الضفه الغربيه حدثنا من بيت لحم